meine damen und herren ich freue mich
dass heute wieder einmal der
französische staatspräsident manuel mata
in berlin ist und zwar zu einem ganz
speziellen treffen nämlich zu einem
treffen mit den regierungschefs aus dem
westlichen balkan und wir haben diese
gemeinsame initiative verabredet weil
wir uns der europäischen perspektive der
länder des westlichen balkans
verpflichtet fühlen will aber
ausdrücklich sagen es geht heute nicht
um beitrittsverhandlungen dazu gibt es
einen fest organisierten prozess der
durch die kommission gesteuert wird
sondern es geht heute darum die
situation wie sie von den verschiedenen
mitgliedstaaten empfunden wird einmal
auszuleuchten und zu überlegen in
welchen fragen wer ein gewisses momentum
einen gewissen impuls brauchen um auch
voranzukommen
deutschland und frankreich wollen die es
gemeinsam tun um einfach auch deutlich
zu machen dass wir eine gemeinsame
verantwortung für diese entwicklung
spüren und um deutlich zu machen dass es
in unserem europäischen interesse ist
dass in dieser region die entwicklung
weiter positiv verläuft das heißt also
es ist heute eine offene diskussion ist
es geht nicht um beschlussfassung jetzt
geht darum dass wir ehrlich und
gemeinsam ins gespräch kommen und das
was uns leitet ist die tatsache dass nur
die gesamte region sich entwickeln kann
es können keine abkommen gemacht werden
zu lasten anderer die dann die folgen zu
tragen haben und diese das rechtfertigt
eben auch genau dieses format es ist ein
informelles format es ersetzt nicht den
berliner prozess als ersetzt nicht die
beitrittsverhandlungen
aber es ist eine gute möglichkeiten auf
den diskurs zu treten und dann zu
schauen wie die jeweiligen bilateralen
verhandlungen auch weitergeführt werden
und deshalb bin ich sehr dankbar dass
der französische staatspräsident nach
berlin gekommen ist begrüßte ihn ganz
artig und glaube dass das heute wichtige
diskussionen sind aber eben ein schritt
auf einem langen
und nicht ein ergebnisorientierter
prozess für den heutigen tag